Hello. My name is
Pete Crocker,
and I'm CEO and cofounder of
Oxford Semantic Technologies.
In this session I'm going to
begin by showing you a short
demonstration that
answers the question
we posed for this session,
who is the greatest
formula one
driver of all time?
This is a question that is
frequently debated,
and a quick search will reveal
many contradicting answers.
This application is
powered by AudioFox,
our high performance knowledge
graph and semantic
reasoning engine.
This demonstration will be
followed by a quick
run through
of a series of
use cases making
use of AudioFox today.
And finally, we lift the hood
on the demonstration and give
you some more detail
behind the engine.
If at any point you
have any questions,
please ask them
in the chat and
we'll be happy to
answer as many
as we can. Otherwise,
come and find us at our booth
during the conference where we
will happily go into
far more detail.
So without further ado,
let's dive straight in.
Our dashboard
includes a series
of controls where you define
the question, here on the left
hand side. And over
on the right,
a set of information
boxes that
show you some of
the statistics
behind the question
being asked
and the data that's returned.
In the middle, we
have the answer
to our question.
First, how long the question
took and then a chart showing
us the score against the time
that the driver was racing.
So what we're showing here is
the race points for the top
twenty drivers and the year of
the last race in which they
participated, all the way up
until just a few
weeks ago when
the last race was
taken here in
twenty twenty one.
Scrolling down we
also get a tabular
view of the results and we can
see here the top ten and a lot
more detail and and statistics
all organized and ordered by
the score based
on our criteria.
To vary the definition
of our question,
we can change
the scoring system
from points to position gained
in a race. So what's
happening here?
For every single race ever
recorded for formula one,
we are looking at the starting
position of a driver.
We're taking where
they ended up,
and we're taking
the difference
to calculate
the positions gained
during the course
of that race.
We're totaling up all of those
differences across
the entire dataset,
and then we're
ordering to find
a person, in this case,
Fernando Alonso,
who's gained
the most positions
over the entire history
of Formula One.
Now that'd be great,
but perhaps
Fernando Alonso was
running in a in
a fabulous piece
of equipment, a fabulous car.
So what we can
then go and look
at is a comparison of Fernando
Alonso only with
his teammates.
How did he do
against the others
running in McLaren
or Ferrari,
for example, when
he was driving
for them? So by
clicking on teammates,
that's exactly what happens.
And here, Jonathan
Palmer jumps
to the top of the list.
So why why is he at the top?
Well, his positions
gained over
the course of history when
compared with his teammates
gives him a score
of hundred and
eighty six. Okay. But
let's have a look.
He's raced seventy six races.
What if, someone else has had
a shorter career
but, again, has,
has recorded more positions
gained against teammate?
Well, again, we can change our
calculation, change
the definition
of our question,
and this time flip over to
calculating an average.
Now we start to see our our
first sort of problem.
We've narrowed the system such
that we're gonna be favoring
those that have
had few races,
in this case we're
seeing pretty
much the entire field occupied
by those with a single race,
and they may have
won that race
or come very high in their
positions gained.
But, really, are
they the best?
They've only raced
in one race.
So let's change the filters of
our criteria. We're gonna up
the minimum races to five.
And while we're here,
why don't we put in
some a requirement
for podium positions.
And there we see our driving
results drop from twenty five
thousand to now a field with
fourteen thousand results.
Our drivers have
come down from
eight hundred and fifty three
to a hundred and eighteen that
are qualifying
with that minimum
of five and three. Okay.
So what have we shown so far?
Well, we've been able to make
our decision for the question
based on race points
or position gained,
whole field teammates
total and average.
Let's come to the final thing
that we're gonna consider for
this demonstration.
When discussing
this particular
application with a former CEO
of one of the teams,
he suggested that
weather really
tests a driver's skills and
ability on the track.
So we can filter based
on the conditions
on the day that
the race took place.
At the moment, we're showing
results for all conditions,
but we can change that.
We can go for
mixed where there
was some evidence
of rain either
on the track
before the race or
we had some rain
during the race.
Or, alternatively,
we can go for full
wet race conditions.
And here you see there haven't
been very many races with wet
fifty four that
are recorded in
in our data, but here,
this arguably is a really good
test of what makes the best
formula one driver.
Now maybe we think that fifty
four is just too low a number
to consider in terms
of number of races.
So we'll flip back to a mixed
conditions and settle there.
And what we see here
is Ayrton Senna,
one of the greatest drivers of
all time comes to
the top shortly
followed by James Hunt.
And in third place,
not too far behind,
Max Verstappen.
If you'd like to try this
application for yourself,
please head to f one
dot rdfox dot tech,
and I'd be interested to hear
how you define
the question yourself.
Please note I've been running
this application locally as I
wanted to show you the true
performance of IDEA Fox.
Given our speed,
your query times are most
certainly going
to be dominated
not by the time it
takes IDEA Fox,
but by the network
latency between
you and the servers
where we're
hosting that service. Okay.
So what about,
what about
the company that that
produces Alia Fox?
We were founded back in twenty
seventeen. We're headquartered
in Oxford in UK,
and we're a spin out
of the University
of Oxford.
We're an independent
software vendor,
and we're proud
to be backed by
Samsung Ventures
who saw promise
in the technology
back in the early
days. AudioFox itself is what
we think of as
a a knowledge graph,
and plenty have been spoken
about knowledge graphs during
this conference.
But we also consider ourselves
a very powerful
reasoning engine,
and more on that to come.
We're open standards
based, built,
as you've, as you might have
already guessed
from our heritage,
on leading research,
and we pride ourselves on on
speed and performance
along with
the reasoning.
We have fast query times,
fast load times,
fast materialization
times when
it comes to reasoning.
And all of this
is built on top
of the engineering
and hard hard
work that's gone
into AudioFox.
We're based in memory.
We're built on c
plus plus We'll
start in finance.
Here, rules are used to chase
down chains of
money flows within
transactions for a bank.
This is in support
of anti anti
money laundering or
AML applications.
Chasing these kind
of chains are
not patterns that
you can simply
detect with regular
graph type queries.
They require vast amounts of
numerical and date
time reasoning,
and most importantly,
recursion as we
go through those
changes.
Next up, we have
some work done
by Samsung Research where they
have built
recommendation systems
that run directly on
the device itself.
Here, they're
providing answers
to
personalized recommendations
that take data from the device
out on the edge and perform
the reasoning
without that data
ever leaving a user's
trusted device.
Samsung Research,
in collaboration with
Oxford University,
have recently
published a paper
demonstrating how this can be
achieved using RDFox
on those devices.
Festo, the automation
company,
were among the first to see
the power of reasoning for
building their electronic
drivetrain
configuration engine.
This solution computes
all the possible
ways in which their components
can be assembled to so solve
their clients' needs.
Built on RDFox,
this replaced an old legacy
relational database
system that
took over sixteen
hours to compute
the capabilities those
compatibilities,
sorry, with something that now
takes ninety seconds.
And so this is all supported
with incremental reasoning.
This approach
completely transforms
how they think
about the problem,
and as it turns out,
has been demonstrated
to be more
accurate than the old system.
OST also partners with Sirius
Research Center in enabling
the digitization
of large scale
engineering tasks.
Here, we're
supporting the design
process. Doing things like
checking
engineering constraints
at massive scale,
building industrial digital
twins to support
their applications.
In a medical setting,
RDFox is being
built into power
decision support.
Here, clinical
knowledge captured
in captured in
ontologies assists
clinicians and
makes suggestions
as they perform
investigations.
In this clinical setting,
embedding ARDFox
within the device
allows these
devices to operate
in real time and potentially
disconnected from
the network,
providing both resilience and
protecting patient
confidentiality.
Finally, Ulm University,
in a project
sponsored by BMW,
have used AudioFox
to integrate
data in the field of
autonomous driving.
The need to do so on device is
clear as is the need
for a highly
performant decision
engine, of course,
AudioFox.
So what makes all
of this possible?
We believe semantic technology
is best suited to
these applications.
It provides a highly flexible
and adaptable data model.
When, for example,
we conceptually want
to map out ideas,
we naturally turn
to drawing graphs.
Ontologies then
support a layering
of concepts and
extend instance
data with domain knowledge.
Integration, in particular,
declarative integration,
bring all of this together,
the sources needed
to answer our
questions. And finally,
reasoning is what makes
sense of it all.
It's required to
bring together
the logic perhaps
captured within
our ontology, the domain logic
logic with data and provide
intelligence to our
query answering.
AudioFox is our
answer to these
semantic needs.
AudioFox provides
you the power
to unlock
applications previously
undreamt of,
flexibility for
how you wish to
shape your data
or the ontologies
you wish to bring
to a problem,
Performance, unrivaled
in the market
at the time of
data importation,
reasoning, the analytics,
and query answering.
And finally, scalability and
versatility. The ability to
scale from the smallest device
up to billions of facts.
I'd next like to focus our
attention on reasoning.
Here I list many aspects of
reasoning that are used
in the applications
I covered earlier.
As you can see
from the table,
others in this
space often define
reasoning as
ontological reasoning,
and some provide
even constraints
through the likes of Shackle.
These are all important.
However, AudioFox goes beyond
this with graph
analytics, data,
and numerical analysis,
the kind of thing you can't
imagine some of
those financial
applications being
possible without.
As well as dealing
with constraints,
both locally, we
can also think
of constraints in
a global setting,
considering the constraints
across the system as a whole.
Finally, we provide
the ability
to combine all of these.
You can bring
aggregation together
with recursion,
negation with class
based inferencing.
If you get a chance later on
during the day to
join the session
with Marcus from Siemens,
he has some really
nice examples
where he's using reasoning to
perform many of
the many of the above.
Next, let's lift
the hood on my
earlier demonstration.
Every time one of
those controls
down the left hand
side is changed,
queries are being
issued to RDFox.
And as you saw,
live results are
being computed
in milliseconds.
Behind these
queries, we have,
as we saw on the info boxes,
over a thousand races,
over eight hundred drivers,
and fundamental
to our question,
over twenty five
thousand results
consulted and
calculated against
for the score to
your question.
There is no additional cash.
We are achieving these results
through the hard
engineering and
in memory approach
that has gone
into and is at
the heart of AudioFox.
Reasoning also plays its part
in precomputing some
of the relationships
in advance. Note,
given the variations possible
in our questions,
we cannot compute
the scores in advance,
just some of those
relationships.
This graphic shows us how we
assembled the data.
Let's start with the sources.
On the left hand side,
we have a database containing
all of the race
data stretching
back to the very
beginning of the sport.
We then supplement this with
images and weather
reports drawn
from Wikipedia.
Once that's done,
a small NLP task categorizes
the weather text
into RDF concepts.
That's where we get
our dry conditions,
mixed conditions,
and and wet conditions from.
There are a number of rules in
the system. Here I'm showing
just one of those,
one of the more
interesting ones
where we establish
a connection
between teammates
through through
common race and constructor
relationships. Essentially,
what's happening
here is a rule
is running as soon as the data
is brought into the system.
A rule is running that tech
compares every single result
with other results
in the system
and where it locates
common races,
that's circuits,
and common constructors,
a new relationship
is materialized
into the graph,
the teammates result.
And this is used
for those queries
where we were running,
where we comparing where we
change the fields to all field
to the teammates.
Through that application,
we've seen some of the ways in
which RDF Fox can
be integrated
into your system.
What I'm showing
here is a much
bigger picture with
all the possible
integration points for
for the technology
. Over on the left hand side,
we have the external
integrations,
and we were doing some of this
when we loaded
RDF through files
and through through SPARQL for
our for a demonstration.
In addition to RDF,
we can be loading relational
data through through SQL.
We can be loading file based
sources and, text
based sources
through Solr to
provide a a text
index as well.
On the right hand side,
we have various
development and
operations aspects
to Ardeafox.
We provide a console where you
can run queries and visualize
results to those queries and
explore your data.
We provide command lines for
controlling the running
of AudioFox.
And of course of course,
we provide developers and
knowledge engineers
with the tools
they need to modify the core
assets of any
solution, Datalog,
OWL, Shackle, and Swell.
In the middle, we
see the components
that make up the runtime
of ArduaFox,
the sparkle API
we've already,
described. The
reasoning engine,
the piece that's
performing, the rules,
act actioning the rules,
for our applications and
materializing those results in
memory into the graph.
We also provide
a a persistence layer.
So we're not only
running in memory,
but the results,
the data that's loaded
and the results
of of materialization are
persisted to disk should you
need to restart the system.
And as we've seen
through applications,
all of this can run
out on the edge
on the smallest of
devices, on premise,
or in the cloud.
For our cloud support,
we provide Docker images,
and we have customers
running on AWS,
Google Cloud Platform,
and Azure.
To conclude, we've seen that
Ardfox takes you from question
to answer in milliseconds.
Through reasoning,
we unlock a new breed of
applications not
possible before.
We're available
on the smallest
of devices to the largest to
cope with concerns
around privacy
and tackle some of the largest
scale problems.
I'll leave you to decide who
the best driver is,
and we've provided
the tools for you.
If you can define
the question,
the answer is only gonna be
milliseconds away.
Finally, let me leave you with
a quote from one
of our customers,
and I'll paraphrase.
Adia Fox makes it possible for
us to do the impossible.
So do you have something you
consider impossible?
If so, we'd love
to hear from you.
During this conference,
please visit us as our booth.
Alternatively, if you're not
able to join us there,
here are some links for you to
follow-up after
the event. Thank you.
And remember, f one dot r d f
fox dot tech if you'd like to
try and answer
that question for
yourself.